Yeah,
oftentimes when people talk about sacred
texts for many people,
that sort of thing that you say to show
how serious you are is,
well,
you know,
we take it,
we take it literally,
but that actually has caused an
extraordinary amount of destruction in
the world.
So I,
uh,
I began with,
I try to take it literally.
So if it's a poem,
it's a poem and if it's a letter who
wrote it and when did they write it and
who are they writing it to?
What was the world like at that time,
if it was history,
but the writer is kind of winking along
the way,
like this is what I'm really saying.
Then you take it with that subtlety and
nuance and even humor.
So all religious texts have to be
interpreted.
And the really dangerous thing is when
someone says,
I'm not giving you my opinion,
I'm just telling you what it says,
because that's actually their opinion.
If you deny human agency,
it generally leads to some sort of
oppression or exploitation.
So,
uh,
everything gets way more interesting
when you start reading it,
literally because you then don't have to
do those awkward explanations.
Um,
one of my,
one of the greatest examples of this is
there's this ancient story about Jonah
who gets swallowed by a fish.
I'm not a whale of fish.
Um,
the counselor says in the ancient texts,
and so the question often becomes a
debate about whether or not a guy really
got swallowed by a fish and you have the
literalist going,
it says he got swallowed by a fish,
he got swallowed by a fish.
And then you have the others going.
No,
it's a larger metaphor.
But what's interesting is the story
begins.
The Assyrians were the worst neighbors.
They were the cruel oppressors who had
made life miserable.
And so this man,
Jonah is told,
go and bless Nineveh.
Nineveh was the capital of Syria.
So the story begins with a man being
told,
go bless your worst,
most heinous enemy.
And uh,
he doesn't.
He goes the other direction.
He runs away,
which I think the original audience
would have cheered this man Jonah on
you.
You go the other direction,
whatever you do,
don't go bless the person who has made
your life a living hell.
So he eventually gets on a boat.
There's a storm,
he's thrown over board and he's
swallowed by a fish.
I think the power of the story is not
arguing about whether or not he was
swallowed by a fish.
I think the story was told to a group of
people to confront them with how they
cannot forgive their worst enemy.
And will the past and the wounds that
you have suffered,
define you and hold you back.
Or can you forgive?
Um,
can you move towards your enemy,
not with violence but with love.
Do the things that have happened to us
define us or is there a love that can
transcend even this?
So this would be a classic example to me
where there's an ancient texts and the
story where you can,
in your attempt to,
uh,
defend it,
literally actually avoid the more
interesting questions of the heart that
I think are the questions the
storyteller is trying to get at.
And yes,
in our world to this day,
taking some of these texts literally has
caused so much violence.
Um,
you read the ancient texts,
you also use your mind,
um,
you listen for what new thing might be
happening in the world.
You read it as a fully orbed experience
and then it actually gets quite
inspiring.